well we're training Riley my daughter
here on how to present her weapon in
case of intruder coming in we're gonna
use my son Colton here today as the
intruder usually intruder seeing a
weapon and we'll stop if he doesn't
she's gonna draw on him and pull the
trigger to stop him she's going to try
to get him to leave the area without
using any force and that's really what
we want to train our kids to do with all
the kids be yes all of our kids in Riley
being our last one
alright Colton come on in stop right
there okay good hang on there son good
you're showing Authority you're loud you
mean business your hands are out there
so even if he's deaf he sees both hands
you know something's going on alright
Colton keep coming stop right there or
I'll shoot
good sorry there son now see you draw
the weapon okay
he knows you mean business your fingers
off the trigger that's good your
Safety's on it's gonna come up when it
comes up the safety comes off because
you've already told him twice third time
it's done right go ahead all right stop
right there he made it this far really
in the perfect scenario I don't even
want him this close to you because a
human can run 25 feet in one second
that's faster than you could get your
sights on and pull the trigger okay it
would good you know Riley is showing
Authority and that's what I wants her to
she used high voice she used good hand
gestures you know trying to stop an
adversary most American dad's aren't
training their 15 horses to to shoot me
and truly come into the house why do you
think it's necessary uh we live in a
horrible world nowadays you know and
being a prepper in an end of a world
scenario I'm gone you know something
happened to me I want my children to be
able to protect themselves and the home
it doesn't does it worry you right here
your dad saying that he might not be
here for the end of the world comes or
something terrible happens yeah that
does scare me how is he a vet yeah it
does but I know that my brothers and my
older siblings will be their friend you
and I can protect myself that's right
that's why we do this